Mary made 15,000 milliliters
of tea for a party,
and she served the tea
divided equally in 8 pitchers.
Her guests drank
6 pitchers of tea.
How much tea did
Mary have leftover?
Write the answer as a
whole number of liters
and a whole number
of milliliters.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
She's got 8 pitchers.
So let's visualize
these pitchers.
So let me see if I can, so
let me draw a pitcher here.
So this is one pitcher.
I'll do my best to
draw a nice pitcher.
So this is one pitcher.
And she's going to put the same
amount of tea in every pitcher.
So the same amount of
tea in every pitcher.
Let me copy and paste
this, so copy and paste.
So she's going to
have 8 of these.
So that's 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, and 8.
So she wants to put the
exact same amount of fluid
in each of these 8.
So she's going to divide
evenly the 15,000 milliliters
into 8 pitchers.
So that's straight up division.
She's going to start
with 15,000 milliliters,
And she's going
to divide it by 8.
She's going to divide into
8 equal groupings or 8
equal pitchers with the same
amount in each of the pitchers.
So 8 goes into, it doesn't go
into 1, it goes into 15 one
time.
1 times 8 is 8, subtract
15 minus 8 is 7.
So bring down a 0.
8 goes into 70, 8 times.
8 times 8 is 64.
Subtract, we get a 6,
bring down another zero.
8 goes into 60 seven times.
7 times 8 is 56.
Subtract again, we get a 4 and
then bring down a zero again.
8 goes into 40 exactly 5 times.
5 times 8 is 40.
And we're not left
with a remainder.
So if we divide
15,000 milliliters
into 8 equal
sections, each pitcher
is going to have exactly
1,875 milliliters.
So that's 1,875 milliliters.
But that's not what
they're asking us for.
They tell us that her guests
drank 6 pitchers of tea,
and how much tea did
Mary have leftover.
So the guests drank 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, leaving 2 pitchers left.
How much total tea is
going to be in that?
It's going to be 2 times 1,875,
or 1,875 milliliters times 2.
Figure out what that is.
2 times 5 is 10, 2 times
7 is 14 plus 1 is 15.
2 times 8 is 16 plus 1 is 17.
2 times 1 is 2 plus 1 is 3.
So what she's left
with, what she's
leftover with is
3,750 milliliters.
Now they want our
answer in terms
of a whole number of liters and
a whole number of milliliters.
And we just have
to remind ourselves
that 1,000 milliliters
is equal to 1 liter.
So you could rewrite this.
This is the total
number of milliliters
that she's left with.
We could rewrite this
as 3,000 milliliters
plus 750 milliliters.
Now the reason I
wrote it this way
is because if 3,000
milliliters-- this is literally
3,000 one-thousandths
of a milliliter.
We already saw that
1,000 milliliters
is equal to 1 liter, so this
piece right over here, this
is equal to 3 liters.
This is equal to 3 liters.
So if we wanted to write it
as a whole number of liters
and a whole number
of milliliters,
this would be 3 liters
and 750 milliliters.